you've been described as one of the most
powerful people in Hollywood do you feel
that you're at the peak of your power is
there more to come
I hope so I never I never want to think
that you know
you've exercised everything that you
have I think that to to feel like
there's a lot more to come and there's
more chapters is very exciting for me
and it inspires me that's why I love
listening to other people's stories I
love to watch The Master Class series I
love to watch
documentaries I love to hear about
people's Journeys because I think that
we can as women can not only Empower
each other and Inspire each other but I
feel like I have a responsibility to
show my grandkids and my children what
getting older looks like you know in
some days I don't feel like showing
anybody what getting older looks like
because I'm tired or I'm you know it's a
Sunday and I want to do nothing so you
have to learn how to like give yourself
that gift of relaxing once in a while
but also I think that it rejuvenates me
like it gives me
a little bit more
energy to go out and try something new
and I love trying new things and
learning new stuff and my kids keep me
inspired and I think that the advice
that I would give to anybody over 50 is
to say if you don't have 300 kids like I
do and that you have to keep going is
like the friends that you make like look
around and look at who your circle is
and try to surround yourself with people
that you can learn from and you can you
know be a buddy with whatever it is
you know whatever that you you know
whatever it is that you love to do find
somebody else in your life make a new
friend find some new people around you
that like to do the same kind of thing
and it makes life more interesting and
more joyful more exciting and you can do
anything that you set your heart to you
just never give up so with everything
the products the new Ventures the shows
the lines for Kris Jenner what's it all
about what's it for what do you want
your legacy to be I think my legacy is
that at this age I was a great mom and I
would I'm a good grandmother that's all
that really matters I mean let's face it
it's just Families First to us always
and I think that that will always be why
we do what we do my goal in life
when I had kids and they became
teenagers and young adults was that
every single one of them had something
that they found they were passionate
about that's great and that I could help
them achieve that as something that
could be their life and their their own
legacy and something that they could
make a living at so that they could be
on their own you know be sustain their
lifestyle whatever they wanted to do
whatever their dream was
and so one by one that's that's my
that's the dream for me